welcome aboard TV lovers I'm your host
and captain Liana Galera
and this is ship worthy the only series
devoted to celebrating the absolute best
couples on TV and in this episode we're
traveling back in time to the wildly
romantic relationship of Outlanders
Jamie and Claire Fraser kissed you again
I know we're all dying of thirst in this
drought Lander as we wait for season
four to finally premiere so I have a
very special treat for all you sassing
ex out there I'm bringing you a brand
new interview with Sam heughan and
Katrina belf talking to me exclusively
about what's ahead in season four and
why Jamie and Claire makes such an
incredible match I think they're soul
mates normally at this point and ship
worthy I'd recap how this beloved couple
first sailed onto our screens and
Anchors Away and then I'd break down the
fans top picks for Jamie and Claire's
best sweet and sultry scenes in a
segment that I like to call naughty or
nice but this is Outlander all of Jamie
and Claire scenes are the best scenes is
it usual today's it between us when I'm
touch you and you with me
no this is unusual it's different I know
this fandom because I'm in this fandom
and I know that during this break you've
already been rewatching your favorite
season 1 episodes and swooning over the
evolution of Claire and Jamie's
time-traveling romance I know this
because I've been doing the same thing
so you don't need me to tell you that
the wedding episode is the finest hour
of television we've ever seen It was as
if I stepped outside on a cloudy day and
suddenly the Sun came out from Claire's
dress to the vows and their first time
together we all know it's perfect I also
don't need to tell you that Jamie and
Claire's chemistry is the strongest of
any on-screen couple that's just a fact
Alan
I would very much like to kiss you and
let's be honest I can't even show you
their Nadia scenes because they're too
hot for YouTube to handle so instead I'm
going to cut to the chase and give you
the moment that I know you're all here
for a brand new interview with Sam
heughan and Katrina Bal just we play
here's a look at what these amazing
actors had to tell me when I recently
joined them on set in Scotland for out
lenders highly anticipated fourth season
oh no back at it again yes we are time
around oh gods yeah they've still got us
old cronies running around how would you
describe Claire and Jeannie's dynamic in
season four at the same time yeah I
think this season we've had a chance to
explore kind of what their relationship
is without the kind of external forces
ripping them apart in the same way as we
have previously I mean it's a more
mature relationship I think there's a
deeper love there it may not be the kind
of on the surface passion that you have
when you're first falling in love but
the passion runs deeper and yeah they're
just a really solid team this season
which i think is really nice for us to
be able to play and we get to see them
you know functioning or working with
each other in a very domestic situation
yeah it's really nice how they interact
with each other and I think for once
yeah we get to breathe for a short time
you trust me
with my luck you guys have now shot five
years together four seasons they always
find their way back to each other what
is it about Jamie and Clara's
relationship their dynamic that makes
them such a good fit together I think
they're soul mates I think that they
were you know they push each other to be
the best versions of themselves no you
really understand each other you know
they've they've been through a lot okay
we have been through a lot and yeah yeah
there's a real understanding there and I
think this season without giving away
spoilers you know they find a place that
they can call home and that for them is
something that they've always wanted
mm-hmm you guys have found quite a few
scenes together at this point is there
anyone in particular that still stands
out in your mind that you just had so
much fun together on I think I still
have a bruise on my tailbone from when
he pushed me and I flew across the room
and landed on my butt that one's still
quite memorable especially when they sit
in certain positions but my hips still
cracking yeah no I remember season one
the one by the river yeah oh my god I
think that like just stands out in my
mind I mean there's so many it's it's
hard to choose like even last season you
know there's some that are quite a
cliched romantic moment in a way like
the running and the beach but I know but
also the reason it's a cliche is because
there was just something so romantic
about that and you know it's always cool
to do those really heightened moments
and I actually I love the beach scenes
especially the last you know when there
was a metaphor you know on the beach and
we were covered in like sand good to see
you wish we was washing us away and it
was just fun seemed to shoot towards the
end of season Georgia
America
dying for more Outlander interviews
dinna fash fans this chat was Sam and
Katrina was just a teeny tiny part of
all the fun content I have coming your
way during this drought Lander before
season four so be sure to keep it locked
to my Twitter page for more exclusive
updates and interviews now I really hope
you enjoyed this Outlander episode of
ship worthy so if you did please voyage
down to the comments section and give
this video a like and tell me what you
think now thank you so much Outlander
fans for watching and until next time
bon voyage TV lovers
[Music]